*Música*
Bienvenidos/as al webinar de Kobo celebrando diez años de impacto e innovación liderados por la comunidad.
Durante los últimos diez años, han llevado nuestras herramientas al campo y nos han ayudado a crear algo mejor año tras año.
Juntos/as, hemos construido una comunidad increíble que abarca más de doscientos países.
Y hoy celebramos esta comunidad y a todas las personas aquí que sienten curiosidad por nuestro trabajo.
Soy Dev More. Seré tu anfitrión hoy. Esta es nuestra agenda.
Comenzaremos con nuestro recorrido de diez años, y Patrick compartirá sobre este viaje.
Luego, tendremos a Tino quien nos contará sobre
actualizaciones recientes del producto y el futuro de la plataforma.
Después hablaremos sobre nuestras nuevas ofertas, donde conversaré con Ayman y Paula.
Luego tenemos a Tala de WHH y Sharon
de Save the Children quienes compartirán su experiencia con la plataforma.
Y al final, tendremos una ronda abierta de preguntas
donde responderemos algunas del buzón de preguntas.
Comencemos donde todo empezó con Patrick, nuestro cofundador y presidente.
Patrick, ¿podrías compartir un poco sobre la historia de Kobo desde sus primeros días
y el recorrido de cómo llegamos a donde estamos hoy? Claro.
Primero, déjame agradecerte, Dev, y a todo el equipo por organizar este evento, y gracias a los/as participantes.
Es increíble ver a tantas personas viniendo
y uniéndose a nosotros/as para discutir dónde estábamos y hacia dónde vamos.
Así que espero con interés la discusión de hoy.
Pero como dijiste, miremos un poco atrás antes de mirar adelante.
Y no muchas personas saben que Kobo tiene en realidad más de diez años.
Realmente comenzó como una idea cuando
Phuong Pham, la otra cofundadora (y también mi esposa), y yo estábamos en Irak.
\[Ininteligible\]
Teníamos una idea muy simple. Hoy parece obvia, pero en ese momento no lo era: preguntémosle a la gente.
Empezamos a usar métodos tradicionalmente epidemiológicos para evaluar
las opiniones y perspectivas de las personas sobre cómo reconstruir después de la violencia.
Pero al hacerlo, nos dimos cuenta de que necesitábamos avanzar mucho más rápido para poder impulsar acciones.
En otras palabras, el tiempo desde que recolectamos datos hasta informar políticas es muy, muy corto.
Necesitábamos ir más rápido y así creamos Kobo. Avanzando un par de años, usamos literalmente
el dinero que normalmente usaríamos para fotocopias y entrada de datos
para crear el primer Kobo.
Me divertí mirando algunas de esas fotos
porque lo que ves arriba a la derecha es el primer Kobo.
No es Android. No es iPhone. Esas cosas no existían. Es un teléfono Mio que
ejecutaba una aplicación Windows mobile.
Esa es la primera versión de Kobo. Pero lo que aprendimos es que funcionaba, que
era realmente posible recolectar datos en el campo
de una manera que nos permitiera avanzar más rápido.
Y esa experiencia de Kobo en el campo es lo que dio el nombre Kobo.
Kobo literalmente significa transferencia. Se trataba de transferir conocimiento desde la experiencia
de las personas hacia quienes toman acción y construyen proyectos.
El siguiente paso fue en la República Centroafricana.
Lo que ves a la derecha es el "hotel Kobo".
Es literalmente una cabaña donde ves esos cargadores solares y cómo estábamos
en el campo sin conectividad, sin ningún tipo de acceso
a electricidad incluso, y aún así podíamos recolectar datos.
Ahí nos dimos cuenta: esto funciona.
Es realmente útil.
La gente empezó a preguntarnos
"¿podemos usarlo?"
Y eso nos llevó a donde Kobo
realmente comenzó a construirse.
Demostró que funciona
en las peores condiciones.
Entonces, ¿cómo construimos desde ahí?
Implementamos en RDC, Uganda, Liberia.
A medida que la gente usaba la herramienta,
la hicimos pública, de código abierto.
Queríamos que fuera un bien global.
Luego IRC y OCHA nos propusieron asociarnos.
¿Cómo podemos mejorarla? ¿Cómo hacerla
más relevante para actores humanitarios
y otros en el campo enfrentando
el mismo tipo de desafío
para el cual esta herramienta
podría ser muy útil?
Durante un año trabajamos
en lanzar básicamente
la primera plataforma global como luce hoy,
aprovechando estándares abiertos, XLSForm
con esta asociación con OCHA e IRC,
haciéndola disponible públicamente
a nivel mundial en nuestro servidor público.
Ese es el punto de partida
del Kobo moderno, si quieres.
Esos son los diez años de los que hablamos.
Y algo increíble pasó desde ese momento:
tomó un año llegar al primer millón
de envíos. Otro año para cinco millones,
otro año para veinte millones,
y ahora hemos alcanzado
mil millones de envíos.
El punto es que hemos crecido junto
a organizaciones como la tuya, entendiendo
cómo mejorar las herramientas
y haciéndolas relevantes
y útiles para actores sobre el terreno.
En 2019, lo que hasta entonces era
un proyecto de Phuong y yo desde nuestras
universidades y a través del tiempo
y diferentes lugares, establecimos una
organización sin fines de lucro, Kobo, que ahora aloja Kobo-
Toolbox y se asegura de que esta visión original permanezca intacta.
La visión de asegurarnos de proporcionar la mejor herramienta más accesible
y de uso gratuito para organizaciones que necesitan datos para generar impacto.
Estamos muy orgullosos de haber sido reconocidos como un bien público digital, aún más orgullosos de ver
el número de personas en este webinar, y más aún de ver las estadísticas de uso en el campo.
Y entonces, nuevamente, ha sido un viaje increíble impulsado por ustedes.
Mencioné los mil millones de envíos. Dev mencionó el hecho de que prácticamente operamos
o tenemos usuarios o personas aprovechando Kobo para
avanzar su impacto alrededor del mundo en cada país.
Y como pueden ver, las estadísticas son claras. Hablan por sí mismas.
Sí. Tenemos algunos usuarios, usuarios muy grandes, que nos ayudan a mantener y asegurar que podamos
continuar ofreciendo la plataforma de forma gratuita a la gran mayoría de nuestros usuarios, ya sean
organizaciones comunitarias, pequeñas ONGs locales, organizaciones para quienes francamente,
KoboToolbox es la mejor solución posible
para generar impacto nuevamente.
Así que no es solo un truco decir que ustedes nos nombraron.
Es verdaderamente la comunidad. Es verdaderamente la experiencia, los socios en Uganda que nos dieron
el nombre, y es verdaderamente a través de la colaboración durante
los años que nos hemos convertido en la plataforma que somos hoy.
Las funciones, las necesidades, la forma de operar Kobo \-
todo fue impulsado por usuarios, para usuarios, con usuarios.
Y continúan inspirándonos en ese viaje.
Y eso sigue siendo muy central en lo que discutiremos a continuación, que es cuáles son algunas de las
prioridades, cuáles son algunas de las direcciones en las que vamos.
Este es un momento crítico porque sabemos que esos sistemas, esos panoramas de información
en los que confiamos están desapareciendo.
Definitivamente están bajo amenaza. Y al mismo tiempo, la realidad del panorama de financiamiento
y las crecientes necesidades y complejidad hacen que los datos sean más críticos que nunca.
Cuantos menos recursos tenemos, mejor debemos
asignarlos, y los datos tienen un rol importante en esa función.
Queremos ser tu aliado para asegurar que no construimos sistemas de información verticales,
sino que aprovechamos la comunidad y sistemas
de información más participativos en el espacio humanitario.
En otras palabras, queremos asegurar que contribuimos a esta capacidad
de crear el cambio desde una perspectiva comunitaria, que tú como actor en el terreno tengas
la agencia y el poder para crear ese cambio.
Espero que te unas a nosotros y hay diferentes formas de hacerlo.
El foro es una parte importante donde puedes ayudar a usuarios nuevos,
y realmente apreciamos a todos los que ya contribuyen a ese foro.
Puedes compartir tus lecciones aprendidas. Es increíble. Hemos aprendido de la práctica y queremos aprender de ti.
Cualquier idea que tengas sobre nuevas funcionalidades, mejoras, o formas de operar, nos interesa mucho escucharla.
Queremos escucharte. Queremos conocer tu experiencia y opiniones, y debes
sentirte libre de contactarnos con sugerencias, mejoras y compartir tu experiencia.
Nos interesa mucho hacerlo. Lo repito: "para usuarios, con usuarios", es para mí
crítico. Y "por usuarios" porque seguimos haciendo investigación, recolección de datos y
asociándonos con organizaciones como la tuya en el terreno.
Estoy muy orgulloso de que hace unos años comenzamos a implementar el programa de embajadores, que es
realmente una forma de reconocer a esos contribuyentes en el terreno que ya están ayudándose
entre sí y empoderando a esos actores en su
alcance y su apoyo a los/as usuarios/as de KoboToolbox.
Y finalmente, debo mencionar a los/as socios/as Enterprise que pueden unirse a
una comunidad de práctica dedicada a organizaciones
de gran escala con amplio despliegue de la plataforma KoboToolbox.
Tienen necesidades únicas y queremos reconocerlo y asegurarnos de brindar
apoyo y compromiso desde nuestros/as socios/as más pequeños/as y locales
hasta nuestros/as usuarios/as clave más grandes.
Nuevamente, quiero enfatizar que esto es crítico para el futuro de Kobo.
Tenemos noticias emocionantes. Estamos trabajando en IA. Estamos trabajando en tantas funcionalidades que
Tino y otros/as describirán en el futuro.
Pero es pensando en ustedes. Es con su aporte, con su colaboración, y con ustedes
impulsando esos esfuerzos a través de esos canales.
Y espero que continúen siendo parte de nuestro futuro.
Te paso la palabra, Dev.
Genial. Muchas gracias, Patrick. Gracias por contar nuestra historia y proporcionar
una visión tan poderosa del futuro que queremos crear con nuestra maravillosa comunidad.
Antes de dejarte ir, tenía una pregunta rápida para ti.
¿Cuál es tu recuerdo favorito mientras has navegado los últimos veinte años en Kobo?
Estaba a punto de irme, y debo disculparme.
Me uniré a otra llamada, pero seguiré en la sesión de preguntas y respuestas. Es una pregunta difícil.
Hay tantos desde la creación y el lanzamiento de Kobo.
Pero diría que todavía estoy muy activo en el terreno. Y cuando voy a áreas pequeñas
en el norte de Irak o en Etiopía, y la gente realmente no me conoce o no me asocia con
Kobo (nunca he sido promocional en ese sentido),
se me acercan y me dicen: "Sabes, estamos usando esta gran herramienta.
Se llama KoboToolbox. ¿Lo conoces?" Bueno, sí lo conozco.
Y es una experiencia increíble ver
qué tan amplio ha sido el alcance y cuán útil ha sido la herramienta.
Algo que francamente fue creado porque lo necesitábamos, porque queríamos poder hacer
ese tipo de compromiso, ver ese tipo de necesidad y
servicio resonar con tanta gente alrededor del mundo ha sido increíble.
Así que, de nuevo, gracias a todos/as por hacer de Kobo el éxito que es hoy.
Gracias, Patrick.
Antes de continuar y pasar a la siguiente sección, haremos una
encuesta rápida de treinta segundos, que debería aparecer en tu pantalla.
¿Cuándo fue la primera vez que usaste KoboToolbox?
Para mí, fue en 2017 cuando alguien
de IRC insistió en que revisara el generador de informes de KoboToolbox por su
intuitividad.
Ojalá pudieran ver lo que yo veo, que son los números llegando en tiempo real.
Es fantástico. Cientos de respuestas ya.
¡Oh, wow! Tino: Ya pasamos el 50%.
Muy bien. Si aún no has votado, por favor agrega rápidamente tu voto a la encuesta.
Me doy cuenta de que como panelista, no puedo votar, pero seleccionaría
antes de 2014, y tendría curiosidad de saber si alguien ha hecho eso.
Eso sería increíble porque serían los primeros días de Kobo.
Te sorprenderás. Bien. Voy a terminarlo. Aquí están los resultados.
Muy bien. Bueno, parece ser 2018-2019
el ganador aquí.
No. En realidad, el año anterior, 2020-2021.
Genial. Es bueno ver una mezcla de usuarios antiguos y nuevos. Así que, sí,
pasemos a la siguiente sección
Muy bien. Me gustaría dar la bienvenida
a Tino, nuestro Director de Operaciones y de Innovación.
Tino ha estado guiando nuestra hoja de ruta
de producto y el equipo de Kobo durante muchos años.
Compartirá con nosotros algunas actualizaciones emocionantes y nos dará un vistazo al futuro de la plataforma.
Te paso la palabra, Tino. Tino: Gracias, Dev.
Gracias, Patrick. Y gracias a todos por estar aquí hoy. Es realmente fantástico tener
un grupo tan grande de la comunidad de Kobo.
Los últimos diez años de crecimiento e innovación detrás de KoboToolbox han sido extremadamente emocionantes para todos nosotros.
Y como pueden ver, no solo la organización ha crecido, sino también nuestros/as usuarios/as.
Ahora tenemos más de un cuarto de millón de usuarios/as activos/as y eso es muy humilde.
Estamos llegando a este momento crucial, no solo por dónde hemos crecido como
organización, sino también por las funcionalidades que aún están por venir.
Pero primero, quiero tomarme un momento para hablar de algunas de las actualizaciones nuevas y más recientes que
ahora puedes usar y que amplían la forma en que puedes usar Kobo para recolectar y analizar datos.
Aquí ya ves una de ellas. Esta ha sido una de nuestras actualizaciones de funcionalidades más anticipadas
del año pasado, especialmente para organizaciones más grandes.
Nuestra funcionalidad de Equipos en esencia permite que, bueno, equipos y, por supuesto, organizaciones más grandes
manejen grupos más grandes de personas que forman parte de su equipo.
Así que puedes invitar colegas, manejar miembros del equipo y centralizar el manejo de datos de esta manera.
Y, por supuesto, si alguien deja un equipo, puedes eliminarlo y así eliminar el acceso.
Unirse a un equipo funciona así. De hecho, transfieres los proyectos existentes del/de la usuario/a,
que luego son propiedad del equipo, y cualquier proyecto nuevo, cualquier formulario nuevo o proyecto de recolección de datos
proyectos que creen en el futuro serán propiedad del equipo en lugar de un/a usuario/a individual.
Esto es muy útil porque si alguien deja el equipo, los/as propietarios/as y administradores/as
siempre tendrán visibilidad, acceso y control total sobre los datos
recolectados en nombre de la organización.
Por ahora, la función de equipos está disponible en nuestro Teams Plan y Enterprise Plan, y en nuestros servidores privados.
Esto también significa, y es muy útil para equipos grandes, que tienes una cantidad
compartida de envíos y almacenamiento que todo el equipo puede
usar, en lugar de tener cuotas individuales.
Y sé que Ayman hablará de esto más tarde. Siguiente,
recientemente lanzamos nuestras funciones de transcripción y traducción automática para todos/as los/as usuarios/as.
Esto significa que ahora puedes convertir tus respuestas de audio de entrevistas.
Y el audio es muy útil para recolectar respuestas abiertas en tus encuestas.
Puedes transcribirlas a texto en muchos idiomas. Y si es necesario, también puedes
traducir esa transcripción a más de ciento cincuenta idiomas usando traducción automática.
Obviamente, la transcripción y traducción manual siempre son opciones.
Y puedes usar nuestra función de editor para revisar y editar cualquier transcripción o traducción según sea necesario.
Esto es muy importante porque las herramientas de IA, como cualquier tecnología, pueden cometer errores.
Por eso siempre te recomendamos, y como ves aquí, te obligamos a revisar antes de
guardar la transcripción. Siguiente, creamos una función para hacer posible no solo
transcribir el audio, sino también hacer análisis cualitativo.
Puedes ir a la siguiente diapositiva. Hicimos posible
analizar los datos que recolectas de esta manera de forma más efectiva.
Lanzamos la función de análisis cualitativo hace unos meses.
Y lo que puedes hacer con ella es crear preguntas meta adicionales sobre estas transcripciones
de entrevistas abiertas, y luego puedes asignar etiquetas, categorizarlas,
resumirlos y lo que necesites como resumen.
Esta funcionalidad hace mucho más fácil realizar encuestas verdaderamente de métodos mixtos.
Esto significa que puedes combinar las ventajas de la recolección rápida de datos móviles con la
profundidad y el rigor de los datos cualitativos.
Por ejemplo, puedes agregar fácilmente una o más preguntas de audio a tu encuesta existente para
poder grabar el porqué de una pregunta, o ¿puedes darme un
ejemplo o una anécdota para ese tipo de datos?
Así puedes combinar tus preguntas cerradas, rápidas,
de opción múltiple con estos datos abiertos mucho más fácilmente.
También significa que puedes hacer esto sin salir de Kobo. No necesitas software costoso y difícil para análisis cualitativo.
Y después de recolectarlo y analizarlo así, lo que ves en la interfaz aquí,
se convierte en parte de la misma tabla de datos.
Tus exportaciones, tu API - todo ya incluye estas respuestas.
Así que solo necesitas descargarlo y visualizarlo y analizarlo junto con el resto
de tu conjunto de datos. Además, hace unos meses, agregamos funcionalidades de registro y seguridad.
De hecho, bastantes. Y estamos muy contentos de haberlo hecho, y estamos
muy orgullosos de haber colaborado contigo y con ACNUR en esto.
Lo que nos permite hacer es proporcionarte los registros de cuando alguien inició sesión en tu cuenta.
Si fue alguien más aparte de ti, tal vez le diste acceso a alguien de tu equipo.
Puedes ver exactamente cuándo iniciaron sesión y desde dónde. Para el historial del proyecto, también puedes ver
exactamente cuándo alguien hizo un cambio y cuándo llegaron los datos, cuándo se hicieron modificaciones
a los datos, al formulario, a los metadatos del proyecto.
Todo esto es extremadamente útil, especialmente si tienes un equipo grande y distribuido.
Si trabajas en muchas ubicaciones diferentes, quieres saber quién hizo qué edición.
Y puedes ver todo eso. Puedes descargarlo. Puedes exportarlo para muchos propósitos de cumplimiento y
propósitos de auditoría.
Esto es extremadamente útil. Y finalmente, hoy nos emociona anunciar que Kobo
será oficialmente certificado ISO 27001.
Esto es extremadamente importante para muchas organizaciones donde es un requisito de cumplimiento.
Y lo que significa, para quienes no han escuchado del estándar, es que básicamente certifica
y asegura que Kobo siempre sigue los más altos estándares internacionales de seguridad de datos para
proteger todos los datos privados: todos
los datos que recolectas a través de tus encuestas, y por supuesto, tus datos personales también.
Estas son todas las funcionalidades de las que estamos más orgullosos de los últimos meses, y creo
que harán una gran diferencia para nuestros muchos/as usuarios/as y organizaciones alrededor del mundo.
Pero estoy aún más emocionado de mostrarte lo que estamos planeando para el futuro cercano.
Para empezar, los próximos meses veremos el lanzamiento
de una funcionalidad de análisis con IA como puedes ver aquí en la pantalla.
Esa funcionalidad en particular te permitirá responder estas meta preguntas que vimos antes sobre
transcripciones de audio de preguntas abiertas de una manera mucho más eficiente y que ahorra tiempo.
También significa, en nuestra experiencia, que es más confiable que pedirle
a muchos/as analistas de datos, analistas humanos/as, en tu equipo que hagan esto por ti.
Nuestros nuevos modelos de IA que estamos entrenando para este propósito analizarán automáticamente la transcripción
y responderán todas las preguntas relevantes en segundos.
Estamos construyendo esta integración con los más altos estándares éticos y en consulta con muchos/as de nuestros/as socios/as y usuarios/as.
Siempre, por supuesto, diseñamos esta funcionalidad para asegurar que haya un humano en el proceso.
Como puedes ver, hay un botón, por ejemplo, para verificar los datos.
Y si no está verificado, sabes que vino solo de un agente de IA.
Esa funcionalidad en particular realmente acelerará el proceso. Por ejemplo, ahora podrías recolectar
cientos o miles de audios de respuestas abiertas y luego analizarlos en un
un solo día o en una sola mañana, en lugar de dárselo a muchas
personas para transcribir y analizar durante días o más probablemente semanas. A continuación,
nuestra gran iniciativa insignia en la que estamos trabajando es nuestro editor de formularios con IA.
Esto integrará un asistente de IA por primera vez, y te ayudará
a dar y recibir retroalimentación sobre tu formulario.
Mientras diseñas los borradores, puedes obtener retroalimentación inmediata.
También puedes usarlo para crear preguntas de encuesta basadas en tus indicaciones.
Y, por supuesto, muy importante, estamos agregando una forma de cargar indicadores existentes o
materiales de orientación que puedas tener en tu organización o en tu sector.
Imagina tener un experto en encuestas, un especialista en métodos siempre a tu alcance,
siempre listo para darte retroalimentación, para decirte cuál es la mejor manera de hacer una
pregunta en particular, que podría decirte que mejores tu pregunta de consentimiento, y así sucesivamente.
Estamos entrenando este agente de IA. Todavía estamos en las primeras etapas, pero lo estamos entrenando para
ser muy, muy cuidadoso, no solo para ser lo más ético y confiable
posible, sino también para usar la orientación metodológica y capacitación adecuada disponible en nuestro sector.
Y como resultado, una vez que esto esté disponible, creo que marcará una gran diferencia en nuestros sectores
y en el mundo sin fines de lucro para crear mejores encuestas mucho más rápido. Y finalmente, estamos
trabajando en incorporar más funciones de manejo de casos en Kobo.
Nuestro objetivo es permitirte rastrear beneficiarios a lo largo del tiempo y hacer que los estudios longitudinales sean mucho más fáciles de gestionar.
Hemos escuchado a muchos/as usuarios/as que nos dijeron que es extremadamente importante
para ellos/as que Kobo siga siendo fácil e intuitivo de usar.
Y por eso tenemos mucho cuidado al agregar estas funciones bastante avanzadas para asegurarnos de que no
saturen la interfaz y no la hagan difícil de usar en la práctica.
Si te interesa unirte a nuestra investigación de usuarios sobre esta función, nos encantaría saber de ti.
Por favor, háznoslo saber. Habrá una encuesta al final del webinar.
Puedes agregar tus datos ahí y marcar una casilla. Nos encantaría
tenerte y hablar más con tu equipo sobre esto.
Bien. Antes de devolvérselo a Dev, tenemos mucho planeado para hoy.
Tengo un llamado final. KoboToolbox siempre ha sido, como escucharon de Patrick, liderado por la comunidad.
Realmente dependemos de ustedes. Así que, si tienen otras ideas para nuevas funcionalidades, grandes o pequeñas,
mejoras. Ya veo algunas llegando hoy aquí.
Pero realmente donde queremos escucharlos es en el Foro de la comunidad.
El Foro de la comunidad está hecho para que compartan ideas, voten por ideas de otros/as usuarios/as.
Así que, por favor, si aún no lo han hecho, regístrense en community.kobotoolbox.org,
creen una cuenta y compartan lo que tienen en mente.
Y por supuesto, interactúen con otros/as que ya han publicado ideas.
Pueden votar por ellas y demás. Por supuesto, el foro también es genial, como escucharon de Patrick,
para ayudarse mutuamente, aprender unos/as de otros/as, y
hacer eso también marca una gran diferencia para nuestros/as miles y miles de usuarios/as.
Así que gracias a quienes están aquí hoy y ya son muy activos/as.
Nuestros/as embajadores/as y usuarios/as avanzados/as de la comunidad, realmente los/as amamos.
Así que gracias por ser parte de esta comunidad Kobo en los últimos años. Y, sí, de vuelta a ti, Dev.
Gracias. Gracias, Tino. Y gracias por todo el
trabajo que se ha invertido en hacer de la plataforma lo que es hoy.
Sé que muchos/as miembros de la comunidad estarán muy contentos/as
de escuchar lo que escucharon hoy sobre las próximas capacidades.
Y sé que nuestro equipo de producto está muy emocionado de trabajar con nuestra comunidad
mientras desarrollamos estas capacidades.
Antes de pasar a la siguiente sección, tenía una pregunta para ti.
Esto surge a menudo, y también
veo un par de preguntas en esa dirección.
Así que pensé en preguntarte mientras estás aquí.
Como sabes, la plataforma es conocida por su accesibilidad,
su simplicidad y su intuitividad.
Mientras trabajamos en integrar IA, ¿cómo crees que
impactará la forma en que las personas recolectan datos en terreno? Tino: Excelente pregunta, Dev.
Sí. Y rápidamente, creo que una de las cosas más importantes
para nosotros y para muchas personas aquí hoy es que Kobo es una plataforma gratuita.
No solo es de código abierto, sino que queremos asegurarnos de que siga siendo una plataforma gratuita como organización sin fines de lucro.
Nuestra misión es ayudar a muchos/as de ustedes. Así que lo más importante es que nos enfocamos en nuestra oferta principal:
Recolectar datos de la manera más accesible posible
dentro de ciertos límites, por supuesto, eso es algo que nunca cambiaremos.
Todas estas nuevas funciones de IA, por supuesto, son extras.
Son cosas adicionales con las que estamos experimentando. Y sí, pueden hacer que la
creación de encuestas sea un poco más rápida y quizás mejor en algunos casos.
Pueden hacer el análisis más rápido. Y son servicios agregados, y estamos experimentando
incluso con otras formas de ayudarte a usar IA para realizar preguntas y demás.
Pero al final del día, nuestras raíces son muy claras, y nos muestran que nada
reemplazará a un/a entrevistador/a humano/a que pueda hacer entrevistas cara a cara.
Lo que podemos hacer es facilitar muchos de los otros procesos, hacerlos un poco más rápidos y eficientes.
Y ya sea que eso sea IA o simplemente otras mejoras de software, siempre veremos dónde
podemos enfocar nuestra energía. Bueno saberlo.
Muy bien. Entonces, antes de pasar a la siguiente sección, tendremos otra encuesta.
Y esta es sobre qué actualización de funcionalidad
te emociona más escuchar.
Bueno, no es sorprendente que la IA esté
generando tanto interés. Para mí, definitivamente es el manejo de casos sin conexión.
Creo que nuestro sector merece una capacidad de manejo de casos que sea
fácil e intuitiva de configurar
Muy bien.
¿Tenemos los resultados? Y aquí están.
Gracias a todos/as por votar. Muy bien.
No es sorprendente. El análisis cualitativo con IA
llega a la cima, seguido de cerca por las transcripciones automáticas.
Excelente. Gracias a todos/as por participar. Habrá una encuesta más en un momento.
Ahora pasemos a la siguiente sección.
Muy bien.
En esta sección, hablaremos con Ayman, quien lidera nuestros esfuerzos de asociación, y
Paula, quien es gerente de proyectos en nuestro equipo de Servicios para Socios.
Nos hablarán sobre nuestras últimas y mejores ofertas.
Ayman nos hablará sobre Teams y Enterprise,
y Paula nos hablará sobre los servicios para socios.
Quizás hayas notado que recientemente ha habido bastantes actualizaciones en el sitio web.
Hemos trabajado arduamente para recopilar comentarios y alinear
nuestros planes y servicios con las diversas necesidades de nuestra comunidad.
Todas estas actualizaciones han sido resultado de todo ese trabajo. Ahora me encantaría
darle la bienvenida a Ayman, quien charlará con nosotros sobre el plan Teams.
Hola, Ayman. Ayman: Hola, Dev. Dev: Ayman, me encantaría conocer tu opinión sobre
cómo surgió el nuevo plan Teams. Ayman: Gracias, Dev.
Como mencionaste, nuestro plan Community y Professional son principalmente para usuarios/as individuales.
Con el plan Professional para grandes esfuerzos de recolección de datos, ha habido una
evolución natural en esta comunidad para trabajar más colaborativamente, y respondimos a eso
con la oferta de equipos porque múltiples usuarios/as querían beneficiarse de una sola suscripción,
lo cual funciona bien para organizaciones.
Todos los proyectos y datos serían propiedad del equipo.
Básicamente, si un/a miembro individual se va, su trabajo sigue accesible para el equipo.
Por supuesto, viene con una cuota mayor de envíos, seiscientos mil envíos por año,
y almacenamiento ilimitado, que puede compartirse con todo el equipo.
Genial. Aquí mencionaste una cuota mayor de envíos.
¿Podrías compartir un poco cómo se ven exactamente esos números?
Y después de eso, tengo mucha curiosidad de conocer tu opinión sobre si los/as socios/as están
interesados/as en operar en muchos equipos,
¿cómo deberían ver nuestras ofertas? Sí.
Vamos a empezar con las cuotas de envíos. Básicamente, si te suscribes al plan Teams
de forma anual, obtienes seiscientos mil envíos para usar
en cualquier momento del año por todos/as los/as miembros del plan.
Básicamente, no hay cuota asignada a una sola cuenta.
Se asigna a todo el equipo. En cuanto a usar en múltiples equipos,
creo que la suscripción al plan Teams viene con un equipo, y este
equipo viene con la capacidad de agregar equipos adicionales al original.
A medida que agregas más equipos, realmente te mueves hacia el uso organizacional de la plataforma.
Entonces, en ese punto, la oferta Enterprise podría tener más sentido y ser una buena opción.
Entonces, esa es una gran transición
para hablar sobre nuestras dos ofertas Enterprise diferentes.
Ayman, me encantaría que
comparar estas dos ofertas. Ayman: Claro.
Básicamente tenemos dos ofertas empresariales como mencionaste.
La primera es la oferta empresarial de nivel de entrada.
Viene con diez planes de equipos, básicamente integrados en la oferta, y no hay
límites en envíos o almacenamiento para todos los miembros del equipo de la organización.
Y luego tenemos el servidor privado empresarial, que da a nuestros socios su propio servidor dedicado de KoboToolbox.
Y puede alojarse en veinticinco países o incluso en tu propia infraestructura local.
Entiendo.
Solo para asegurarme de que entiendo correctamente, cuando mencionaste
25 países e infraestructura local, digamos que una organización grande
como CRS o IRC o Mercy Corps quiere múltiples
servidores privados, digamos uno en India, uno en Sudáfrica.
¿Podríamos hacerlo realidad?
Absolutamente. Sí. Como dije, tenemos alojamiento en aproximadamente
25 países, y tenemos algunas opciones de alojamiento en nuestra nube.
Y también podemos hacerlo en tu propia infraestructura.
Así que, básicamente, sí, podemos configurar organizaciones de esta manera. Dev: Genial.
Gracias. Y también, ¿podrías contarnos un poco sobre todos los diferentes
tipos de servicios que reciben nuestros socios empresariales? Ayman: Sí.
Básicamente, las ofertas empresariales - no son solo el software para nosotros.
Fundamentalmente, representan una asociación estratégica entre nosotros y el socio empresarial.
Colaboramos estrechamente hacia su éxito.
Así que nuestros socios empresariales tienen acceso a un gerente de éxito del cliente dedicado.
Proporcionamos treinta horas de tiempo reservado para capacitaciones y consultoría.
Tienen acceso ilimitado a KoboToolbox Academy para cualquier necesidad de incorporación o, ya
sabes, capacitar al nuevo personal en KoboToolbox.
También incluye soporte prioritario en un día hábil
Y eso es solo parte de las funcionalidades.
Hay más. Dev: Genial.
Muchas gracias, Ayman, por conversar con nosotros. Y también gracias a
todo el equipo de alianzas de compra por hacer un trabajo tan excelente
cuidando a nuestros socios y asegurando que nuestras
ofertas se alineen con las diversas necesidades de nuestra comunidad.
Gracias. De nada.
Ahora, me encantaría que Paula se una para hablar sobre nuestros servicios para socios.
Hola, Paula. Hola, Dev. Hola a todos/as. Dev: Paula, tienes una
trayectoria tan rica y fascinante en monitoreo y evaluación en múltiples países.
Tengo curiosidad sobre qué te hizo
unirte al equipo de servicios para socios de Kobo.
Sí. Trabajé con Kobo durante años también, y vi que muchas organizaciones en el
mundo no usan Kobo a su máximo potencial.
Muy a menudo se ve que usamos servicios muy básicos, análisis de datos muy básico, y
la misión de este equipo es apoyar y obtener lo mejor de Kobo
Entiendo.
Gracias. ¿Podrías compartir un poco sobre cómo específicamente los Servicios
para Socios ayudan con algunos de estos desafíos que enfrentan nuestros socios a los que te referías?
Sí. Entonces, trabajando directamente con las organizaciones que trabajan directamente con
comunidades que necesitan funcionalidades específicas o formularios específicos para ayudarles a
entender cómo usar mejor Kobo y cómo
mejorar lo que están haciendo, siendo más eficientes y reduciendo el riesgo de fallas.
En nuestro equipo tenemos profesionales de M&E y trabajadores humanitarios.
Tenemos personas que han trabajado directamente en el campo, así que tenemos la combinación perfecta en equipos que trabajan
directamente con Kobo, que tienen la experiencia con Kobo, pero que también han trabajado
directamente con comunidades en el pasado. Gracias.
¿Podrías compartir también
los diferentes tipos de servicios que ofrece nuestro equipo de servicios para socios?
Sí, absolutamente. Como Tino y Patrick mencionaron, nuestro objetivo es también mantener
a Kobo siendo accesible y también
teniendo en el centro que somos una organización sin fines de lucro, y ese es el corazón de lo que hacemos.
También ofrecemos algunos servicios para grandes usuarios y para socios.
Tenemos cuatro categorías básicas. La primera es desarrollo de formularios.
Apoyamos a equipos con la creación de encuestas y, en general, el uso de
KoboToolbox, luego desarrollamos tableros personalizados,
investigación y evaluación, y también soluciones a medida.
Todos estos servicios están adaptados a las necesidades de
socios específicos. Dev: Genial.
Gracias. Estoy seguro de que a nuestra comunidad le encantaría escuchar sobre un ejemplo reciente
de un proyecto de servicios para socios. Sí.
Estamos trabajando con la Oficina Regional de ONU Mujeres
en los Estados Árabes con este proyecto que llamamos TrackIt.
Básicamente, están trabajando en toda la región con más de diez países,
más de cien socios implementadores, y tienen
más de ocho proyectos que han sido rastreados usando el sistema.
Les ayudamos a crear los formularios. Les ayudamos a crear el tablero que ven en las imágenes.
Y con ellos colaboramos para que sea más fácil para todos acceder a los datos.
Y no es solo una casilla para donantes u organizaciones, sino también una oportunidad
para tomar mejores decisiones basadas en la evidencia que están recolectando
Gracias.
Gracias, Paula, por compartir
los diferentes tipos de servicios que ofrece nuestro equipo de servicios para socios.
Y también, gracias por todo el increíble trabajo que tú y tu equipo han estado haciendo. Muy bien.
Hora de nuestra última encuesta.
Y esta encuesta habla de las diferentes escalas en las que
la comunidad usa la plataforma - desde pequeñas
ONGs hasta grandes ONGs internacionales, ejecutando programas a gran escala.
Démosle otros cinco segundos.
Muy bien. Ya tenemos la mayoría de votos.
Terminemos, y aquí están los resultados. Muy bien.
Entonces quinientos a mil envíos
es donde está la mayoría de las personas.
Muy bien. Gracias a todos/as por participar. Y ahora estamos
pasando a nuestra sección de Destacados de la Comunidad, donde tenemos a Tala
de WHH quien hablará sobre
su experiencia con nuestra oferta de Teams, y luego tendremos a Sharon
hablando sobre la experiencia de Save the
Children con nuestra oferta de servidor privado empresarial.
Entonces, primero comenzaremos con Tala. Tala tiene más de ocho años
de experiencia en monitoreo y evaluación principalmente en
la región de Medio Oriente y Norte de África.
Ha trabajado para una variedad de organizaciones, desde NRC
a CESVI, y ahora en WHH.
Tala se especializa en diseñar sistemas MEAL y fortalecer la gestión de información
para programación basada en evidencia, y también tiene experiencia en
diferentes áreas programáticas, incluyendo refugio, medios de vida, educación,
protección y nutrición con enfoque reciente
en las operaciones de Palestina.
Te paso la palabra, Tala. Tala: Muchas gracias, Dev.
Gracias por invitarme a este webinar. Hoy compartiré nuestra
experiencia usando Kobo en el contexto de Gaza, que es un contexto de emergencia.
En el contexto de Gaza: Gaza, como todos saben, ha
enfrentado una de las crisis humanitarias más severas.
Y en los últimos dos años, la situación se ha deteriorado rápidamente, con hogares,
hospitales, escuelas e infraestructura severamente dañados y destruidos.
También ha habido desplazamientos masivos y continuos con más del 90% de la población
desplazada y a menudo múltiples veces. Y la situación humanitaria ha colapsado.
Esto ha creado un entorno operativo complejo y de alto riesgo. Y
algunos de los desafíos operativos que enfrentamos.
¿Puedes pasar a la siguiente? Gracias.
Algunos de los desafíos operativos que enfrentamos incluyen restricciones de acceso
y movimiento, que limitan nuestra capacidad de llegar a las personas necesitadas.
Los bombardeos continuos también representan un riesgo serio para nuestro personal y las comunidades que servimos.
Y el desplazamiento constante es otra capa de complejidad, haciendo que la prestación
de servicios sea inestable. Los suministros de ayuda son limitados, lo que significa que debemos
verificar, monitorear y priorizar continuamente nuestros servicios.
Y las necesidades de la población evolucionan constantemente en este entorno, y con eso en
mente, nuestros sistemas de datos deben ser adaptables, oportunos y transparentes para
guiar nuestra respuesta y mantener la rendición de cuentas y la confianza.
Entonces,
WHH trabaja realmente a través de socios locales y nuestra respuesta de emergencia se ha centrado principalmente en
tres sectores, incluyendo nutrición y alimentos, refugio,
NFI y WASH. Siguiente, por favor.
Y dadas las realidades
con las que trabajamos, Kobo se ha vuelto esencial para nuestra respuesta.
Nos ha permitido monitorear actividades de forma remota, especialmente cuando el acceso directo es limitado o inseguro.
También nos ha dado datos oportunos y digitalizados, datos que apoyan nuestra toma de decisiones.
Y Kobo funciona de manera flexible, y el hecho de que sea ampliamente adoptado por
nuestros socios locales facilita nuestro trabajo.
Y, específicamente el plan Teams, ha añadido la estructura
y la escalabilidad que necesitamos para sostener nuestras operaciones.
Entonces, con eso, hemos podido adaptar nuestros
flujos de trabajo de datos para ajustarse a las realidades sobre el terreno.
Y esto ha sido especialmente importante para nuestras actividades de verificación y monitoreo,
donde Kobo nos permite recolectar datos incluso en áreas de difícil acceso o cuando no hay acceso a Internet.
La evaluación rápida de necesidades también nos ayuda a guiar nuestras respuestas de emergencia.
Y cuando se trata de expandir nuestra red de socios locales, Kobo ha apoyado nuestro
proceso de preevaluación para CBOs. Porque Kobo funciona sin conexión y en
teléfonos inteligentes, es accesible para nuestros equipos, nuestros socios, incluso en las
condiciones más desafiantes. El plan Teams
ha traído varios beneficios clave que han fortalecido nuestra respuesta.
El primero es la escalabilidad. A medida que nuestros proyectos se expanden, podemos escalar nuestras
operaciones sin interrumpir nuestro flujo de trabajo existente.
Segundo, ha descentralizado la gestión de proyectos, lo que nos permite alojar todos
nuestros proyectos bajo una cuenta organizacional y preserva el conocimiento institucional dentro de WHH.
También facilita la coordinación entre las oficinas nacionales y los equipos de campo.
El tercer punto es que la función de gestión de equipos, que permite el
control de acceso basado en roles, nos permite alinear los permisos con nuestra estructura de personal.
Porque tenemos coordinadores/as principales, consultores/as, voluntarios/as
y recolectores/as de datos, esto encaja perfectamente con nuestra estructura.
Esto no solo promueve la responsabilidad, sino que
también protege los datos sensibles, especialmente en tales condiciones.
El último punto es tener soporte mejorado del equipo de Kobo
mismo. Y tal vez,
por último de mi parte, solo algunos comentarios y reflexiones sobre el uso de Kobo.
Los comentarios del campo han sido generalmente muy positivos, y Kobo es visto como fácil
de usar, práctico y empodera a las comunidades locales.
Mirando hacia adelante, WHH quiere capitalizar en
fortalecer la gestión de equipos para ayudarnos a crear un entorno más estructurado y seguro
para la recolección de datos y promover la biblioteca como un
espacio centralizado para plantillas y formularios estandarizados.
Gracias, y te paso la palabra, Dev. Dev: Gracias, Tala.
Gracias por tomarte el tiempo de estar aquí y por compartir
tu experiencia sobre la
plataforma y tu trabajo en curso en Gaza.
Muchas gracias. Ahora, tendremos a Sharon
compartiendo la experiencia de Save the Children con nuestra oferta de servidor privado Enterprise
oferta. Sharon es una profesional del desarrollo digital.
Lidera esfuerzos para expandir y estandarizar la recolección de datos a nivel mundial
dentro de Save the Children. Tiene experiencia trabajando en
ONGs locales e internacionales, junto con experiencia en RSE e iniciativas de educación
digital. Sharon aprovecha la tecnología para amplificar el impacto.
Tiene una maestría en Gestión del Desarrollo de la London School of Economics.
Te paso la palabra, Sharon. ¡Bienvenida!
Gracias, Dev. Hola a todos/as. Soy Sharon Sagues.
Soy la product owner asociada de recolección de datos digitales en Save the Children International,
y hablaré sobre nuestro camino usando KoboToolbox como herramienta estratégica organizacional
para la recolección de datos en nuestros programas. Como saben,
Save the Children trabaja en todo el mundo, alcanzando millones de niños/as cada año.
Ya sea respondiendo a emergencias o mejorando la educación, los datos nos ayudan a entender qué
funciona, dónde debemos mejorar y cómo aumentar el impacto.
Con miles de empleados/as y socios recolectando datos, necesitábamos herramientas seguras,
escalables y fáciles de usar. ¿Por qué?
Porque la captura precisa de datos es esencial para identificar actividades que brindan mejores
resultados, permitiéndonos aumentar el impacto hacia nuestros avances para los/as niños/as
más marginalizados/as y desfavorecidos/as.
Antes de KoboToolbox enterprise, nuestra recolección de datos enfrentaba tres problemas principales.
Primero, era insegura. Los datos se almacenaban en laptops o archiveros, y muchas herramientas
no cumplían nuestros estándares de protección de datos. Segundo, era ineficiente.
Los equipos de MEAL pasaban horas procesando datos manualmente y creando encuestas desde cero con poca
orientación sobre qué herramientas usar. Tercero, teníamos datos de baja calidad.
Demasiadas herramientas significaban que los datos no podían compartirse o compararse fácilmente.
Los formularios en papel seguían usándose, y la falta de estandarización dificultaba el análisis.
Estos desafíos dejaron claro que necesitábamos una solución segura, escalable y estandarizada.
¿Qué hicimos al respecto? En 2022, lanzamos nuestra instancia privada Enterprise de Kobo
exclusiva para las oficinas de Save the Children; luego, iniciamos la incorporación masiva desde 2023.
Esto nos dio mejor control sobre el almacenamiento de datos, acceso a nuevas funcionalidades y mejor manejo de datos para nuestros/as usuarios/as.
Apoyamos el despliegue con orientación de incorporación, migración de datos desde instancias públicas de Kobo,
una biblioteca de formularios basada en la funcionalidad de colecciones públicas,
y soporte continuo de mesa de ayuda para nuestros/as usuarios/as.
Para algunas oficinas, esto no solo fue una transición desde herramientas digitales antiguas, sino una
transición completa hacia la recolección digital de datos desde papel.
La transición no fue fácil, pero una fuerte coordinación interna y una gobernanza clara nos ayudaron a superar esos obstáculos.
Y en seis meses, más del 95% de nuestras oficinas estaban usando nuestra instancia de KoboToolbox.
Ahora, está bien integrada en nuestro monitoreo y evaluación, y
tenemos millones de envíos anuales que lo demuestran.
Pero no hay mejor manera de expresar esto que a través de las palabras de nuestros/as colegas que han
destacado, por ejemplo, una mejora en sus prácticas de seguridad y protección de datos,
ahorro efectivo de tiempo, y mayor confianza mediante el uso de una herramienta estandarizada.
Podemos escuchar a algunos/as de ellos/as en el próximo video.
Kobo es una plataforma mágica que ahorra tiempo.
Eficiente. De nuestra parte sería la seguridad y privacidad de datos.
Entonces, Kobo es en tiempo real, amigable para las personas
Estamos orgullosos/as del progreso que hemos logrado hasta ahora.
Y aunque el trabajo está lejos de terminar, hemos aprendido algunas lecciones clave en el camino.
En el lado de "hacer", logramos aprovechar una demanda real
de cambio de nuestras oficinas nacionales, lo que ayudó a impulsar el impulso.
También tuvimos el apoyo de líderes clave, lo cual fue crucial porque tener defensores en la cima
hace una diferencia real. Entregamos comunicaciones claras y simples tanto a nivel global como país
por país, y esto ayudó a mantener a todos alineados. Nos preparamos tanto como fue posible, pero nos
mantuvimos flexibles para adaptarnos a las necesidades de cada oficina país.
Luego, escalamos funcionalidades existentes, por ejemplo, como mencioné, para crear
plantillas compartibles trabajando con nuestra comunidad MEAL para construir una biblioteca organizacional de formularios
de clase mundial para cada una de nuestras áreas temáticas. Del lado de lo que "no hacer":
Como un equipo pequeño de tres personas, nuestro consejo mirando atrás es no subestimar los recursos.
Implementar tecnología a escala necesita personas dedicadas y tiempo.
También recomendamos no subestimar el rol de los socios locales, que puede variar ampliamente, y
todavía estamos trabajando en la mejor manera de alcanzarlos a todos.
Y para nosotros, la tarea de migración también fue más grande de lo esperado, pero fue esencial para una transición fluida.
Y finalmente, como sabes, la agregación de datos entre países es compleja.
La digitalización a través de KoboToolbox y la creación de formularios estandarizados son solo los primeros
pasos para construir un sistema de reportes organizacional verdaderamente comparable
Así que, eso es todo de mi parte.
Gracias por escuchar. Agradecida de ser parte de esta comunidad, y brindemos por datos que impulsen un cambio real.
Gracias, Dev. De vuelta a ti. Dev: Muchas gracias, Sharon.
Fue fascinante escuchar el recorrido de Save the Children usando
KoboToolbox tan intensamente en las oficinas país de manera descentralizada hasta
ahora, cómo se está implementando de manera tan organizada.
Muchas gracias. Muy bien.
Ahora tomaremos algunas preguntas de nuestra comunidad.
Muchas gracias por todas estas preguntas. Y, como mencioné, haremos nuestro
mejor esfuerzo para responder tanto como podamos.
Pero si no podemos responder tu pregunta,
nos pondremos en contacto por correo. Sharon, la primera
pregunta es para ti. Parece haber mucha
conversación en la comunidad sobre cómo las organizaciones que adoptan
una plataforma, digamos KoboToolbox a nivel centralizado,
cómo logran que funcione
financieramente desde la perspectiva de si están facturando
las tarifas a usuarios individuales u oficinas de país.
¿Podrías compartir un poco sobre cómo
lo maneja Save the Children? Sharon: Claro.
Sí. Dividimos el costo de todo el
paquete Enterprise entre las oficinas de país que lo usan.
Y lo hacemos de manera equitativa para todas las oficinas.
Y sí, se factura, pero es un bien compartido, así que
compartimos el costo. Dev: Entiendo.
Gracias. La siguiente
pregunta es para Tala.
Tala, mencionaste que gran parte de tu
trabajo se realiza a través de socios implementadores locales. ¿Hay
lecciones específicas que quieras compartir
cuando trabajas con socios implementadores locales donde todos
usan KoboToolbox?
Sí. Gracias. Es una buena pregunta. En realidad, tratamos de capitalizar lo que
los socios tienen y mejorar los sistemas que ya tienen,
para no imponerles nada nuevo.
De cierta manera, eso también facilita su trabajo,
y nuestro trabajo también.
Entonces, la lección principal es trabajar con lo que tienen y mejorar los
sistemas que ya tienen, ya sea desarrollando los
cuestionarios o mejorándolos, o el flujo de datos y las conexiones de
las herramientas y formularios dentro de su Kobo.
Gracias. Entiendo. Gracias.
Bueno, nos quedan dos minutos. Así que tomaremos una pregunta más.
Tino, esta es para ti. ¿Kobo trabaja con agencias gubernamentales?
Digamos que una agencia gubernamental está ejecutando un proyecto y quiere su propio
servidor de KoboToolbox.
¡Sí! Por supuesto. La verdad es que muchas organizaciones e instituciones gubernamentales ya lo hacen.
En muchos casos, recolectan datos con Kobo y luego en algún momento deciden por
razones de soberanía de datos o cumplimiento legal, que necesitan los datos en su propio servidor.
Y entonces nosotros (creo que Ayman mencionó esto antes) apoyamos
235 países diferentes donde los datos pueden alojarse localmente en nuestros diferentes centros de datos.
Entonces, si eso es una necesidad para casos de uso grandes y
complejos, ya sea una agencia gubernamental u organización, eso es ciertamente posible.
Y apoyamos a varios de esos ministerios o instituciones más grandes de esa manera.
*Música*